all right I know people have been
waiting for this moment for nearly a
week we are going to get into this
week's episode of hatred mail brace
yourselves for the only information that
can successfully penetrate a tinfoil hat
Patriot mail written by Patriots who
hate David Pakman because America and
because freedom
all right this week's hatred mail really
needs no introduction other than to say
best grammar ever take a listen to this
Pakman you're an idiot
grow up Jesus you are propeller able
David Pakman please explain to me your
logic for which the validity of is an
argument hinges up Tom the amount of
correctness political and is of your
line does recommendation bogus arguments
are you trolling us right now I had the
same question for the person who sent in
this hatred mail my favorite line from
this and really it's one of the best
lines we've ever had in hatred mail Pat
explains the validity of is and
arguments and then I also liked
correctness political it's like one of
those languages where you put the
adjective after the noun right
only that's not English yeah English
does not fall under that umbrella
unfortunately but yeah so okay well
listen I am going to put forth an
argument which is of is and in and that
I think is going to undo a lot of that
correctness political that people might
be reacting to I know that we go after
the your your thing a lot believe it
yeah but if you're saying you're an
idiot you got to use the right you're in
that case right if you only listen to it
you wouldn't know that it was once again
another instance of where the
contraction for you are was misspelled
as why oh you are that's in almost every
hatred mail I barely even pointed out
anymore pad because just about every
Hadrian male has that mistake in it turn
hatred mail into something positive by
using the coupon code hey tree at forty
when you sign up for membership at david
pakman.com slash membership it will save
you 40 percent and for that we can all
thank this this hatred who
made is and of and arguments thank you